there are many great reasons to visit
Japan I had three trillion of them in
Japan the first thing that comes up if
you google Conan is an anime character
named the Detective Conan he's a man
who's trapped in a child's body hey
Conan and this really blew my mind they
have a city named Conan town clearly
someone's been making a ton of money off
the Asian version of me for 24 years so
the other night I reasonably asked Japan
to pay me three trillion yen next week I
am flying to Japan and coming to Conan
town to collect my money
[Applause]
I landed in Tokyo and almost immediately
felt out of place roughly I found
someone who would help me fit in I'm
here at a company called Japanese lunch
they teach etiquette language culture
this is Ms pita Yama you were going to
help teach me how to be very polite and
proper while I'm in Japan
yes okay konichiwa konichiwa I just met
you yes what's matter what I do you push
him I pushed you I didn't push you was I
too close to Japanese people just bored
Wow I know no shake hands yeah then this
distance is very comfortable I'm a
hugger
I like to hug is that batting no I'm a
hugger no I'm not - you're laughing
you're not my girlfriend okay about that
later
you got the mic type what am I not your
type
what's wrong Oh
what's wrong with my face just anyone
else anyone else here so you keep your
distance
all right so close bow from the waist
well have a different face completely
really an ugly non-starter you have a
business can you show me yours
Here I am at this those are your skirt
ah not ah yeah I see what what's wrong
without rude sounds rude ah okay here I
am i this those arrows good I have a
card yeah I just want to see my card yes
there it is that gets the attention
you don't like lands in America you
don't tell people your face is ugly and
I don't like you I don't you said not my
type
yes okay but you keep saying you've said
it many times just to close pretty good
all right and enter a home when bring
again yes yes
is it read to read to get money cheap
cheap watch I give you my watch
yes it's nice to say nice watch yes yes
yeah okay
getting that back you know no now mm-hmm
I know there's different sushi yep just
a moment please
oh we got Sun she's my assistant with um
where is she you weren't with just
hiding in the corner yes
did you hear everything that she said
about my face yes No very handsome might
be oh well hello
the man sees an attractive woman in
Japan can I go this is my first time to
see a human being maybe you haven't seen
a human being made those noises before
excuse me hi where did the way to go
where's the waiter where did she go
waiter what are you doing why do you
keep going will you look you're like a
person in a cuckoo clock
oh please you may go back Hey yeah back
to your corner well when you need yes I
you'll just magically hear she's around
the corner if you need to please call
her yeah well she'll probably get here
pretty quickly because she's right
behind
yeah did you like gum no very rude
what's rude about gum what's the problem
with gum no later some chewing gum yes
it's really rude what's a problem with
it people see you I'm polite and you
don't respect others please yes I need a
lot of gum please swallow this do you
think that will be accepted here in
Japan why are you like this she does not
think I will be accepted by many people
in Japan Oh No do you think I will be
popular with the Japanese women oh yes
yes am i considered attractive do you
think to Japanese what
it's terrible let her answer if you keep
the distance Howard but I'm a very
expressive person I move I jump this is
who I am and you're asking me to deny
Who I am as a person and not be myself
these are the things I do
I knew it and I'm someone who do you
like that yeah you like this this is the
part you like but this part rest go away
I've been here just a few hours you're
the first person I've met in Japan okay
you stayed you want a little this over
here all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I exercise all the time you and I need
that just yeah do you think very fluffy
I think girls like your yarmulkes very
lean in America in America and the lean
ah please sit sit here yeah you know
where I'm gonna go when I go hey daddy's
gonna be back
[Applause]
you